a violent confrontation between police
and protesters in the Congolese Capital
Kinshasa
protest organizers say the government's
way to enrollment process is a sham
they're demanding an international audit
of the entire electoral commission
governing party supporters say they'll
resist what they consider attempts to
discredit the government
if the opposition Corps approaches we
will come as well we are in power we can
call all the forces including the Army
and the police to stop this opposition
from challenging the president
since he won disputed elections in 2019
critics say president Felix shisakedi
has made a series of moves aimed at
consolidating his power that includes
appointing partisan judges hand-picking
loyalists to run the Electoral
commission and declaring a circled state
of Siege in the eastern North kivu and
the Turi provinces areas known to be
opposition strongholds
it is very sad to see police deployed by
President Felix shisekadi blocking
protesters in a democratic State we know
that it is his time but we will continue
to fight because we have the right to
save this country Phoenix has failed at
all levels and he must be conscious of
this
police in the capital block another
presidential candidate from joining the
demonstrations thousands of opposition
supporters have promised to stay on the
streets
we are determined to continue the
protest whatever happens if they block
us we will always find another way to
protest against the election process in
security and also living conditions of
our people
opposition leaders have called for
another rally outside the Electoral
commission headquarters next Thursday
but with just seven months to go until
the general election the opposition is
worried time may be running out to
ensure a fair election Barbara angupa Al
Jazeera